a new study being done right here in
nevada could change the game when it
comes to covet 19. torah university
nevada is trying to look at how
antibodies are being produced by people
in the las vegas community but they need
your help oracle mana sat down with a
doctor involved in the research to
explain how it all works
the goal of our study is to understand
how the las vegas metro area and clark
county as a whole
have been affected by the virus
cova that causes covet 19
immunologically so we're looking at
antibodies and so we want to understand
how how are the antibodies being
produced by our community and so what
that tells us is it tells us a little
bit about protection it tells us about
who has been infected and it tells us
about who is getting vaccinated all of
this information can help us understand
where we need to put our resources as
the public health efforts and lead to
hopefully
new treatments and vaccines that will
help prevent and treat this disease
and if you can kind of break it down
maybe in layman's terms in terms of once
you collect this blood sample how
exactly you go about figuring out that
information that you're looking for yeah
after we collect the blood we bring it
into the lab and we separate it into a
couple different sections so first we
take out the liquid and within the
liquid are the proteins which is also
where the antibodies are so that's where
we're going to find
those
molecules that are going to help protect
us against the virus
we also are looking at white blood cells
we want to know how the white blood
cells are able to function
in people who have been vaccinated
versus have not been vaccinated people
who have had the disease versus people
who haven't had the disease and what
we're hoping to find by looking at these
white blood cells is if there's any
indication to
how we might predict if someone is going
to have severe disease or mild disease
and so
it sounds like you're looking to get
these samples from both folks who are
unvaccinated and vaccinated correct
yes we are looking to get samples from
people who are vaccinated and
unvaccinated people who have been
infected and people who haven't been
infected we really need to look at
everyone to get a clear picture of
what's happening in our community
well if you're interested in
participating head over to our website
8newsnow.com